if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go I always wanted
to be part of something bigger yes
blonde is about a group of people who
find themselves in early Hollywood at a
time of extreme depravity and debauchery
and excess
[Applause]
it's the biggest thing I've ever tried
to do
it was such an insane time it was just
wild like the Wild West
story follows multiple characters that
had an ambition to be a part of
something bigger than themselves we've
got to innovate we've gotta
ANS Jack Conrad is the biggest film
actor at the top of his game and he's
calling a lot of the shots take two
frames off the tail and Fremont's head
Manny is our guide through the story
these are eyes and ears from an
outsider's point of view he's a dreamer
someone that is trying to find his way
you can feel it in is something bigger
than life
Nelly is an aspiring actress she's like
a tornado hello
and she's not gonna let anyone stand in
her way I got here on my terms not
theirs
it's a uniquely different cinematic
experience and it's going to be truly
amazing
it shows a side of Hollywood beyond what
you could have imagined
I mean so much trouble
people are going to be really shocked to
see how crazy it was is this gonna be
what it's gonna be
it's really funny at times look at these
idiots
it's really sexy at times the film is so
big it's really an epic
it's just phenomenal
[Applause]
hey my grand
laughs
[Music]